britney's conservatorship case is back
in court and our lauren zema is on the
scene
britney spears in tears today in court
the pop star called in to testify for a
second
time in her ongoing conservatorship case
and things got
emotional e.t had our producer inside
the courtroom and
brittany told the judge that she wants
charges filed against her father
charges of conservatorship abuse now
britney's father has said in the past
that he loves her
and wants nothing but the best for her
and there was a major ruling
the judge allowing brittany to hire a
lawyer of her own
choosing that is matthew rosengart and
today we're learning much more about the
high-powered attorney
i focus on entertainment litigation
corporate litigation
rosengart a former federal prosecutor
has rep steven spielberg ben affleck and
sean penn penn has called him a
tough-as-nails street fighter
his core values service and collegiality
and civility i think it's a real
game-changer
legal analyst rachel stockman who's been
following the case says it's a smart
move
i think he would be a vigorous advocate
for britney spears
i think when britney spears is looking
at this case
she's saying i'm seeing some kind of
light at the end of the tunnel i'm
seeing
maybe we can have an end to this
conservation
and there's another twist in the war
between britney
and her dad e.t obtained these legal
bills which indicate that britney's own
estate was billed
nearly 1.5 million dollars by jamie's
attorneys
including 500 000 for media matters
i asked samantha stark about it she
directed the now emmy nominated
documentary framing
britney spears the numbers to me
seem outrageous very high
we got a 45 page document yesterday
about fees just for jamie's lawyers like
how does a judge
parse through that and know what to
approve how much time are they given to
do that
you